and I understand that sometimes you'll
have it correct me please if I'm if I'm
mistaken here but a number of outfits
and you have that character walk in and
kind of choose in Miami know it what's
in I thought I forgive me okay well
we'll redo that one I don't know why I
thought I had where that what eras do
you find I like to choose oh you like to
choose I for some reason is my Brad
calls me a method costume designer he
said that I get right down into the very
center I peel all those layers of the
onion away and dress actors from the
inside out and I try to do my homework
to such an extent that i have a favorite
costume going in that i've already shown
to the director and usually have gotten
you know a good response or you know
done my selling job there and i give
them choices of course because sometimes
they've been working on the role a long
time before they get to me often
especially really serious actors and
when they put something on that i am
rather keen on and the director is liked
when he's seen the pictures of the
research and they don't stand a certain
way or get that right body language i am
the first one to throw it away i have no
ego investment in a costume even when
it's a kind of favorite of mine if you
don't if it doesn't work on them on
their bodies and you know good actors
you know when you hit the right costume
because of their body language it
changes totally changes its I've always
said that the costume is the bridge from
the actor to the character that's the
first time they start really feeling
that characters when they put on the
costume can you give me some physical
examples of the body language I mean do
their palms open up or they're well one
my favorite of all times is Geoffrey
Rush In quills and going to back to one
of my first movies but it happens almost
on every movie but it was
so extreme with Jeffrey when I put them
arcade Assad because he's very languid
and loosened and he's fluid and and you
know I not sloppy in his body movements
but very you know like his body has no
bones in it and when he put on the
Marquis de Sade's costume the white
costume that he wears for 25 years in
prison his whole body language changed
he looked like an aristocrat from a ocn
painting and he started walking
differently and the actor that he is he
had me make one just for him to wear for
the two weeks before he started shooting
while he came to England just to
rehearse he worked day and night he'd
come when we were shooting the lunatic
asylum it was was to be Charenton at at
Luton who he walked would walk around
the grounds all the all the very you
know sculptured palatial grounds of
Luton who in that costume you'd see him
out in the shadows in the hedgerows and
stuff walking around in the marquis de
sade costume with the little stacked
heels and he would be so different than
without it
you